I think Cleveland had a great game plan
they dominated the boards they actually
played great defense for a team that
wasn't a great defensive team they they
had Isaiah Thomas's number and LeBron
still the best player on the planet to
bring in Reggie Aloysius Miller he was
on the call last night what did you
think before the game started reg was
going to happen well one of two things I
thought you know we go into the rest
versus rust debate and I felt that
Boston would have a better rhythm coming
off that epic you know seven-game series
with Washington so they would be in
better rhythm than the Cavaliers who had
been off nine days so I thought possibly
Cleveland looked off to a slow start
because it had their legs or their
rhythm was off and the Celtics you know
because of that you know two days ago
going seven games versus the Wizards you
know shooting the basketball will
probably be in their favor but if you
look at the first half you know one of
my keys last night was that they had to
win the three-point battle which they
ended up doing by one but most of those
threes came in the second half they were
2 of 16 at halftime and a lot of those
threes were wide open so the shooting
and the rhythm wasn't there and the rest
for the Cavaliers because if you look at
LeBron Jean in that first half he didn't
settle for jump shots
everything was attacking the paint and
he looked refreshed rejuvenated inspired
and that picked up the Cavaliers
basketball and Tristan Thompson they are
going to have to find an answer because
to me he was game ball because he set
the tone at both it was before but more
importantly he has always been the
kryptonite to Al Horford when he was
with the Atlanta Hawks he dominated
those teams on the officer glass and he
really set the tone
LeBron's playing as well as he's ever
played why now Hey look I mentioned this
on the air last night I mean this is his
14th season and he is playing his best
basketball in the playoffs
and I can remember my 14th year I was
nowhere near where I was you know my 6th
and 7th year and he is playing the best
basketball I arguably ever seen now
that's saying a lot because he's had
some pretty good playoff series but his
overall game and his ability to attack
and lead it's the best I've seen I don't
know if he on a mission like he said he
has nothing to prove but he isn't
playing
he is playing inspired basketball which
has lifted his teammates to go to
another level and that's a lot to say
for another you know bit in the league
there fall now you're saying this is the
best postseason performance ever
for LeBron not ever by anybody know by
LeBron James
not ever by LeBron James at our feet
okay I go back to that series a few
years ago versus Detroit when they had
Chauncey and those guys when he had like
what 29 30 points in the fourth quarter
I thought that was a pretty impressive
series the series he had when he was
with Cleveland versus Paul Pierce in
those Boston Celtics I thought was
pretty good but overall the 9 a no start
for the Cavaliers and his numbers
they've just been spectacular
I saw a couple of stories today that the
Celtics should trade Isiah Thomas I
guess looking at him and saying do we
want him for the long haul do we want to
spend 40 million dollars per year on
Isiah Thomas we have the number one
overall pick so instead of trading the
pick let's trade Isiah Thomas what do
you think of that I sure hope not and I
hope there's some loyalty from the
Celtics towards Isiah Thomas you know
we're so quick to you know go on to the
next best thing
you know not only has Isiah Thomas
rejuvenated his career but he helped the
Celtics brand to getting to the Eastern
Conference Finals and the story the
stories that have come out obviously you
know the passing you know of his sister
and the toughness he has shown with
getting you know his grill rocked and
playing inspired basketball it has
brought this up his brand back so I hope
he's rewarded and and not treated I
think you need to surround him and build
around him because if you look at the
Celtic landscape you know what the
Cavaliers wanted to do was basically
take IT out of the game which they did
they don't have its secondary backup
they don't have a secondary score Al
Horford who has played fantastic
throughout these playoffs you know he's
he's a great role player if you look at
the numbers but he's not going to give
you you know twenty five and ten on a
nightly basis they need secondary
secondary scoring help so they need to
build around Isiah in my opinion it's
not going to Reggie Miller he's got game
two coming up tomorrow night in Boston
would you rather have the Celtics future
of the Lakers future all the Celtics
future you got the number one pick you
have cap Penn excuse me kappa billy and
you've got Isiah Thomas who is an
all-star an MVP candidate and you've got
a great young coach in Brad Stevens I
think you know going forward the sky's
the limit I think they're two two and a
half years ahead of Danny Ainge as
planned
Danny Ainge didn't think they were going
to be in the conference finals this
quick I mean this team was just you know
they blew this came up three years ago
and look how quickly quickly they've is
rebounded you know they've got guys that
you know we're dropped in a second round
starting for them so now they are ahead
of schedule I think it's if your subject
is the future is very bright more
nowadays the Lakers with Magic Johnson
look you've got the number two pick but
you've got some decisions to make you
know it is Alonso ball going to be your
pick he's going to be that guy that's
going to change your franchise do you
package that pick possibly for Paul
George to Indiana I you know are you
trying to get to the playoffs next year
just Paul George is that in your future
with Indiana be attractive to that so
there's a lot of decisions magic is
going to have to make it Rob pálinka the
new general manager Mark Cuban yesterday
on the show talked about how once they
were a limb
that the Mavs tanked
they tanked every game no memo was sent
out he just said they played younger
players who that wasn't the best team to
put on the floor but he put out younger
players
what are you what's your response to
Cuban admitting an owner admitting that
his team tanked it goes on all the time
and I admit it no reg no it goes on all
the time and I really believe the
Commissioner is going to have to address
this because look every time we do a
game and we look at the box score and
and we're coming into an alpha game and
you see guys that are playing major
minutes or starting that should not be
playing it makes you question you know
what is what are these franchises really
trying to do and I applaud Cubans for
coming out and being honest but why this
is the problem we reward that we've
rewarded Philadelphia for so many years
for not playing guys and basically
tanking and continuing to stockpile
picks it's not there it really isn't
because we're rewarding losing as
opposed to trying hard you know I say go
back to everyone should have a fair shot
of winning that number one pick if it's
the San Antonio Spurs the Golden State
Warriors the Cleveland Cavaliers the
teams with the best records compete with
the Phoenix Suns the Brooklyn Nets the
Lakers or so whomever because it's not
fair to tank just to get the number one
pick not play your best players to get
the number one pick it's just not fair
no where's the competitive juices in
this league that's why people think you
know that games are rigged at times
because teams and owners they're not
they're not claimed by the same rule
then well McLovin said this yesterday
what if you took out the top four teams
in the West top four teams in the East
and then everybody else is in the
lottery equal opportunity in the lottery
so that so there's no tanking that goes
on you're not getting an advantage by
tanking at the end of the season
top four teams get home court advantage
there they're there for a bigger picture
whereas the other teams you're all in
the hopper here to get the number one
overall pick well I think you would get
a little bit more competitive basketball
I think teams not with winning records
would probably compete more they would
play players like the fact that the
Brooklyn Nets that Lopez and some of
those players at the end of the year
that last game for rest was a joke
that's a joke yes seriously that is a
joke and that's why the Commissioner has
to do something about it because you're
making the game of basketball laughable
you know for them to come out and say
they arrested they're not going to play
full rest when they haven't played all
year it's a joke when you have teams
with playoff implications and feedings
on the line you're going to rest it's
just a joke have you ever had a moment
like Mark Jackson and Jeff Van Gundy had
the other night with the Golden State
game that they started talking about
dessert early early and again like if
you ever had to flute what's the oddest
thing you guys had talked about look
when you hit into a blowout like we had
last night and like what they had in
Game two like your mind wanders because
you can only talk about so many X's and
O's in a 25-point beatdown so I get it
you know we've been there you know your
mind tends to wander it happens but you
have you talked about dessert we talked
about this early been all over the place
trust me I am NOT going to fault that in
fact it's kind of kind of good what they
were talking about the probably Sunday I
like that oh I thought it was funny and
those who yeah they're they're fun
they're they're avid and concentrate
yeah they are great they do a great job
do you have great memories of Boston I
love I love the city of Boston I always
loved playing here now we used to get a
head speed in you know danger out to the
87 going against Larry Legend and Kevin
and the cheese and and those guys we
used to get our heads beat in but it was
such a learning
for a young Reggie Miller to be on the
old you know parquet floor with the dead
spots and the fans were on top of you
and you know you had no hot water you
know in your locker room and yeah those
were cool and to have a playoff series
versus Larry legend that's when the
rifleman shock person and him were you
know talking trash you know that was my
first introduction like how this is cool
I mean the playoffs this is what it's
all about the intensity and you know we
knocked Larry out of a game and he goes
in the back and whatever drugs they gave
him he came back out like Superman
so wait how did you know female of
boxers how did you not Bird out well I
don't know who gave him a shot to the
back because that's when he had a bad
back at the time those may have been the
rifleman who kind of said a hard back
pick on him and knocked him out of the
game and I believe this was game 5 when
it was Augusta 5 so we were on the road
game 5 up double digits Larry legend
goes out he's in the locker room and the
next thing I've never heard this before
even the great Michael Jordan in the old
Chicago Stadium the sound level in the
decibel level with Larry legend emerge
from the locker room I had never heard a
crowd goes crazy before when he ran out
immediately checked in and drained two
three and they were on their run to
winning Game five and winning the series
but that's when I fell in love and I
just had to be a part of playoff
basketball for most of my career
take that rifleman take that rifle to
him I run hey Reggie I think a bird 3232
nine and seven in that game five against
you guys an inspired performance again
we thought we had we had it you know we
had knocked out the head of the snake
and we thought he was done and he goes
in the back and probably get the shot in
his back and comes out like Superman if
he had stayed healthy and Len Bias when
they drafted him at they had him on Wow
can you imagine
great and and rag2 they had Reggie who
Reggie Lewis named I did mean they were
set on great drafting great young
players that were going to surround and
learn from McHale and bird and the
future was was supposed to be so bright
for both of them
remember Len Bias and sharperson were in
the same draft that year did you face
bias never in college no never
man he was crazy athletic he was like
domine yeah it's unfortunate that you
know the passing of him very unfortunate
I heard he was great but I never faced
them I never solved Reggie's got the
police coming to your hotel no I'm
looking out my window here and you know
good old Boston strong is Popo there
what that it's the Popo there apropos no
it's not there okay ambulance is going
by they never like that that pulled the
fire alarm in your in your hotel in
Boston today Wow did that ever happen in
Boston no it never happened here in
Boston it did happen somewhere on the
road maybe New York it happened when my
kid no father I could see where they
would do it too
Spike Lee may have done it to you in New
York oh that was sassy we did there was
a lot of things that went on in New York
that but that's a different discussion
that it different you survive you
survive game two coming up tomorrow
night on TNT Marv Albert Chris Webber
David Aldridge and Reggie Aloysius
Miller thanks reg good listen last night
then tell the boys we settle oh yes
Dorothea Dorothy thank you and Dennis
you guys are the best as usual that's
Reggie Miller the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience